[Applause]
thanks Jeffy and thank you for coming
given the weather outside so so some of
you the part of this talk will be quite
old hat but I hope they'll be
interesting things for everybody in the
talk so I'm going to talk about the
limits to prove and when we start we
start with formal proofs and there
really are two people at the late 19th
century early a 20th century who really
almost synonymous with the introduction
of formal proof one was a superstar in
mathematics and the other is largely
unknown or very little-known the way
little-known one is Gottlob Fraga and
what I didn't realize before I was doing
this talk is that in fact his in 1884
one of his papers had actually really
introduced the notion of formally
quantified variables and the quantifiers
that we use now then later in the 1890s
he spent a huge amount of work on a
monumental what was intended to be two
volume tome on the basic laws of
arithmetic and how to develop everything
from logical principles the other of
course is David Hilbert who started had
already had a great career doing other
aspects of mathematics but starting in
right at the the turn of the 20th
century started to focus on questions
about formal proof and on formalizing
mathematics and his foundations of
geometry in 1899 was at a level of
formalism that even Euclid never had and
in his famous address at the math
congress in 1900 where he set out his 23
problems he very clearly focused on the
question of how to do things with formal
procedures to solve all sorts of
problems and his program which he
proselytized
a lot especially in the 1920s was really
the program of mechanizing formal proof
and he's famous for the statement
there's no ignore mobis we don't know in
mathematics so he's definitely was like
both of them were optimists about formal
proofs Fraga unfortunately got a little
pessimistic when Bertrand Russell came
along in 1901 and pointed out you know
this concept of the your system you can
talk about the set of all sets well
there's an unfortunate paradox in that
and he together with his advisor Alfred
North Whitehead decided work the next 10
years trying to formalize all of
mathematics and you might be familiar
with this volume which is just volume
one or not all the volume one of the
principia mathematica this volume being
the only part on page 360 just a short
distance from the end proves one plus
one equals two so that's you know a lot
of people sort of think well that was
the end that's all they got to but they
actually got to two more volumes of
similar size and then gave up now they
formalized a lot and introduced things
like type theory but they really didn't
get all that far in formalizing
mathematics proper and there was a
reason for that
and that is the first limits to proof in
this girdle in his famous 1931 paper
showed that their project would be
impossible if you wanted to express all
the basic arithmetic properties of the
natural numbers any formal system movie
could come up with that's consistent
would have statements that can either be
proved or disproved touring came along
and inspired by girdle and extending
these ideas showed that the halting
problem is undecidable in particular
that there's no algorithm to determine
whether or not other arbitrary
algorithms halt and this inside hangs
problem was actually one of Hilbert's
problems that was the inspiration for
his
work of course this doesn't mention
proof so we just tweak it there's no
system of proof that can prove whether
or not arbitrary algorithms halt
so proofs very limited well there is an
infinity in these limits to proof so
gotaland completeness we've got all of
the natural numbers and Turing's
undecidability of the halting problem
not halting means running forever
arbitrarily large time bounds so there's
no impossibility result for either if
say numbers larger than 10 to the 10 and
the 10 or running times that big come
into play and well we live in a finite
universe with finite lifetime so what's
the how can we think about the
finiteness well a quantum theory tells
us Planck length is kind of the smallest
unit unit of information actually if you
take a Planck length cube it's got six
sides and you can store about at most
one bit per side which is about six and
if you take the size of our universe and
do it all out the number of cubic Planck
clients is really not that big and the
actual the time of a universe is really
very small if we even if we measured in
nanoseconds of the form of computers we
do now and so by you know just to
compare these we've got two to the 50th
which is sort of comparable there and
even a year of computer time is really
not that far in the exponent from the
total life of the universe so you know
maybe maybe these infinite things aren't
really a problem and the first places
where where this came up was was in the
notion of computing we're computing in a
finite world so we're making when people
first did physical realizations of
digital computers they realized that
efficiency was important in fact von
Neumann was famous for well known for
going around that famous for it and
saying well we have to make sure that
these algorithms run quickly
why wasn't well the computers would
actually break down before the
computation finished with the early
computers so that was the reason he was
interested or a little bit more reliable
now but it was very quickly realized
that they were good
algorithms algorithms that were bounded
by number quantities that are polynomial
functions the input size and bad empire
gorillas that are exponential and in the
60s people realized that many problems
have often surprisingly good algorithms
but others only seem to have bad ones
and this motivated the definition of
polynomial time which probably is
effectively due to Cobham so it runs in
polynomial time if it's number of steps
--is Grose's end of the order 1 and for
simplicity we focus on decision problems
where the answer is just true false or
yes/no and define P to be the set of all
decision problems with polynomial time
algorithms so that's the the notion of
computation in a finite world what about
reasoning in a finite world so without
loss of generality we can represent any
finite world or and the states the
actions whatever you want by finite
sequences of bits I really don't want
this going off to infinity and there we
can get to a much simpler logic than
Frey Gore Hilbert we're talking about
which is propositional logic and going
back to George Boole so we've got
boolean variables and connectives and or
not and implies so what are the things
we might want to understand about this
logic well we want us the properties of
boolean formulas these formulas express
constraints that our world has to
satisfy and the worlds are possible
assignments of true false values to
these boolean variables so we've got
properties like satisfiability a formula
is satisfiable true if in some worlds
tautology it's always true and
unsatisfiable if it's always false and
all possible words so here's a simple
one and it's nice you can go back and
forth between tautology and
unsatisfiability just by sticking knots
in front ok so the first of these
problems that get tackled is the problem
of satisfiability you know this audience
B probably probably we're going to be
you know a little bored for the next
couple minutes but so if it has boolean
variables we can try all assignments
so the question is is this problem of
deciding whether a formula is
satisfiable
is it polynomial time of course it's
open but there is this related problem
where we have a polynomial time
algorithm which is given a boolean
formula and a truth assignment to it
does that truth assignment make the
formula true so there we do have some
polynomial time task and a formulas at
if and only if there exists some tea
that makes it true which means there
exist some tea such this verification
algorithm that's checking whether tea
set makes it true
since yes so tea is a proof that F is
Sat and the other piece about it is it's
also very short in fact it's linear in
the size of of the input so of course
cook and Levin famously generalize this
notion of having something that's easy
to check like checking like this
satisfying assignment assignment
satisfies the formula makes it true with
non-deterministic polynomial time so we
can write it I'm going to write it in a
formal way so these are decision
problems that have a polynomial time
associated verification algorithm such
that a string X is a yes for the
decision problem if and only if there's
a short proof y such that this verifier
checks out and says why does prove that
X's is is is a yes for that problem and
by short we mean polynomial so of course
Sata's np-complete that's the big result
of both cook and and Levin on opposite
sides of the Iron Curtain which means
that if Sad is in P then P equals NP and
figure that out
and the Clay Institute will give you
some some Bills of that form so million
dollars so boolean formulas so these are
the same problems we had before so we we
know really have a decent understanding
of satisfiability obviously big open
question
about it but what about tautology or
unsatisfiability so for this we need to
think about what constitutes a proof of
tautology or satisfiability well here's
the conventional textbook proofs so
we've got some axioms like excluded
middle inference rules like modus ponens
and a proof is a sequence of lines each
which follows either from an axiom or
from an inference rule and the last
thing you've got is the thing you're
proving so but another thing that's also
a proof would be truth tables these are
also proofs they're very easy to check
locally you can just check how each more
complicated formula depends on the
previous simple ones and then you just
check the final line so that is a proof
as well and cook and reco realize that
there's something more general going on
here we need a system for expressing
proofs so that proofs are easy to check
and that's the key property of both the
truth tables and these these inference
systems so we think about it is this
polynomial time verification algorithm
that's going to check the proof taking a
formula and it's supposed proof that
sound it outputs true if it does then
you've got something that say a
tautology or unsatisfiability or
unsatisfiable and it's complete for
every tautology there is a proof such
that the verifier likes it the verifier
checks it out so this is very much like
the definition of NP but there's one
critical difference there's no
requirement that this proof p be short
okay so that's the sole difference from
the definition of NP this easy to check
this having the sufficient verifier is
is the key piece so so the the once we
have this we need a notion of complexity
truth tables aren't as good as as these
other inference systems for writing down
proofs so the complexity of a proof
system will
exactly capture this question of well
how big does the proof actually have to
be so C of F it's a it's a it's a
numerical bound or numerical function
that tells you given how big your
formulas how big the proof has to be so
truth tables have complexity at least
two to the end you just need two to the
N rows to write them down if they're in
variables in your formula now C of n so
if we could shallow find a system where
C of n is polynomial in n then we'd have
a proof of tautology or unsatisfiability
being an NP because this would be that
one extra missing condition about the
shortness of proof on the other hand if
we can show that it's impossible for all
proof systems for unsatisfiability it's
impossible for this to be polynomial and
end for all proofs of unsatisfiability
then we would conclude that P is not
equal NP and here's the quick idea well
unsatisfiability is the complement of
sets who would say that that's not an NP
but if we're in P so the complement of
any problem in P is also in P and since
Sat is in NP its complement if it were
also in P its complement and better be
so sad is not in NP so all right so this
question of how big proofs are is really
the fundamental question of proof
complexity and it's a very interesting
question from the point of view of of
what it's trying to say because proof
complexity just doesn't doesn't just
bound what deterministic algorithms can
do how long they'll take it bounds non
deterministic algorithms as well so it
only measures how big proofs have to be
how many symbols it takes to write them
down it doesn't say anything about how
complicated is to find them and in
general the the search problem finding a
proof might be as might be require some
form of exhaustive search so finding the
proofs might be much harder than just
writing them down however you might
think well proof systems we came up
with a couple there are actually many
many proof systems went concoct come up
with any deterministic algorithm for sat
with a running time T of n yields a
proof system for unsatisfiability with
complexity roughly like T of n and the
basic idea is if you've got some
unsatisfiable formula we want to prove
its unsatisfiable just run the algorithm
and write down the transcript of all the
states you've been through and that is a
proof that no satisfying assignment
exists if you had a deterministic
algorithm for Sat so that's one way we
can come up with them and this method
actually does relate to some things and
practices will see the proof complexity
program if they could say that is to
prove that specific systems of
increasing strength are not poem
polynomial e bounded so so one of the
way reasons why you might want to do
this is as steps towards proving P not
equal NP you don't actually prove
something stronger potentially that NP
is different from Co NP I won't go
through the definitions but the other
thing is that understanding these proof
systems may also be relevant and useful
in in practice ok so but how do we
compare strength of proof systems so
Cooke and reco said well if one proof
system simulates another if proofs in
one can be efficiently converted to
proofs in the other so it tells you that
proofs in that one can be at most
polynomial then proofs in the original
system and proof systems are equivalent
if and only if they simulate each other
and one of the first systems that class
of systems that cook and were analyzed
by Cooke and reco which they called
Fraga systems and are largely known
elsewhere before this as Hilbert systems
even though Freya had essentially
defined them
much earlier but Hilbert was a big
popularizing a popularizer of them
these are inference systems that are
given to it just like the ones we've
seen the finite set of axioms and
inference rules and the axioms and
inference rules are actually used as
schemas where you get to substitute
consistently in two of the formulas so
for example given this axiom a or not a
we can plug in x and y and say we can
automatically and conclude that this
line is true now a frege's system is any
such inference system that is general
enough to make all possible inferences
after some number of steps might take
you a while and what cook and Rekha
proved is that all of these frege's
systems no matter how you define them
are all equivalent with to each other
they can be the proofs from one can be
converted to proofs and the other and
it's actually not too difficult to prove
now frege's systems and proof systems in
general deal with arbitrary boolean
formulas as input and it'd be nice to
have something a simpler version of
input to deal with and here's a nice
form that's very convenient for as input
to these proof systems so boolean
formulas the CNF stands for conjunctive
normal form if it's of the following
form we've got a bunch of it's an and of
a bunch of clauses each of which is an
or a bunch of literals each of which is
a variable or its negation so this is a
nice flat simple type representation
that happens to be very good on to
represent on computers and to work with
insight and in 68 showed that there's a
linear time transformation that will
convert any boolean formula F into a CNF
formula that has the same satisfiability
properties so we might as well just work
with that CNF formula so we can assume
without loss of generality that our
input is a CNF formula because we could
just quick
we do a conversion of the sort that he
suggested and this is of course part of
the standard proof that 3sat is
np-complete and just for completeness
I'll describe the construction so in
general it works for arbitrary boolean
circuits and these are graphs which have
variables as their input and these
connectives as gates and the main
difference from boolean formulas is that
in boolean formulas there only be one
output edge from from each gate whereas
here you might have multiple inputs and
of course and these can effects
efficiently simulate any poly time
computation and the site and
transformation is is nice you actually
add some extra variables one for each of
the gates okay that's going to express
the value of the gate and then we add
clauses one an and of clauses one clause
to say that each internal gate is
computed correctly and a plus a Clause
saying that the output gate is true okay
so we've got CNF formulas inputs are
dealing with clauses wanted to a proof
system that just deals with clauses and
that's resolution proofs this is a
refutation system for CNF input every
proof line is a clause each line is
either a clause of the input or follows
from two it's got one inference rule one
inference rule only if we take two
clauses and they have variables of
opposite signs than the or of the
remaining variables has to be true
because no assignment can make both
allow both of the two X can make both of
these true and the goal is to derive the
empty clause which can't be made true
because there are no variables in it to
make it true this is sound and complete
for for clauses and it's incredibly
useful in practice so resolution has a
strong connection to formal methods in
CS and if since of I would say about
2000 formal methods for analyzing
software and hardware using Sat solvers
has just really revolutionized the field
of
of analysis for computing and the
general idea is you write a CNF formula
expressing the constraints that any bug
has to satisfy so any satisfying
assignment is the bug so the correctness
of a system is equivalent to showing
that the CNF formula is unsatisfiable
and the fact that we can do write these
even for circuits is is extremely
convenient
now modern SAP solvers are what are
called conflict directed clause learning
or CDCl extensions of DP ll algorithms
and they're extremely successful CDCl
solvers I mean they work well on CNF
formulas with tens to hundreds of
thousands of variables millions of
clauses even that we know that Sat is
np-complete that doesn't actually mean
that they always work and there are
actually a number of ways that people
were initially were trying to solve
problems using these solvers and they
ran into some problems that actually
turned out to have been previously oh
sorry let me back up so let me explain a
little bit about these solvers CDCl N
and D pol so d pol comes from the name
of two papers by Davis Putnam law German
and Loveland the first doesn't have
anything to do with the DPL algorithm
but showed how you could translate first
order logic into refutation search for
CNF formulas the later paper is what
introduced the backtracking search for
satisfying assignments that really and
plug it into the approach of the first
paper that really is the the basis of
the modern algorithms but just to keep
various people happy the the P is kept
in the middle so the it's not hard to
show it say I couldn't even think of
what a reference is it's like folklore
is that if you've got a none set formula
in run DP ll search on it and it fails
that trace thing becomes a resolution
refutation of the original formula but
of us
we'll forum when you derive a clause you
don't get to reuse it so you drive a
clause and you want to use it again you
have to drive it again so that's a very
restricted form of resolution proof CDCl
solvers these are extensions beginning
late 90s 2000s which primarily the new
thing was adding new learned clauses to
the formula at every backtrack and
they're also things like restarts and a
lot of other tricks but you can also
show that resolution covers you know the
traces of these things when they fail to
find a satisfying assignment are
actually resolution refutation z'
of the formulas so resolution really
does capture what these Sat solvers are
doing and as I was mentioning earlier
the there are limits to resolution so
one of the limits is the famous
pigeonhole principle so these four
pigeons want to go to these pigeon holes
for the night and the problem is that
two of them you know at least two of
them are going to be unhappy because
they land in the same pigeon hole so how
do we express this in boolean logic well
we have a variable for each of these
possible edges X IJ says that pigeon I
maps to hole J we have clauses that that
say so this says every pigeon is mapped
somewhere this says it's only mapped to
one place and this says every hole gets
at most V say every hole gets at most
one pigeon and this is unsatisfiable by
the pigeonhole principle
well Hawkins showed in 1984 that every
resolution refutation of the pigeonhole
principle requires exponential size now
remember exponential and doesn't have to
be too big before this is larger than
the number of symbols you can represent
in the universe and so resolution can't
count and then later res burrows
actually showed that doesn't matter how
many extra pigeons you have you
resolution still can't figure out
and in practice this really is an issue
sat solvers can't refute the pigeonhole
principle when it's like roughly 20
variables or maybe a little bit more
than that so even though they can handle
thousands of variables this is only a
few hundred variables and they get stuck
another class of formulas where these
solvers have major problems are random
formulas so take a random k CNF formula
for K Bikram bigger than equal to 3 so
that by K CNF the means the clauses are
size K and if we choose some linear
number with a sufficiently large
constant and the linear number its
unsatisfiable almost surely but almost
surely every resolution refutation
requires exponential size so there are
loads of other problems that one can
choose show resolution is bad at one of
the there's a general technique to Bence
asan and wig ursin that if you can show
that there even has to be one large
clause one clause of big size then the
whole proof is huge provided the input
doesn't have clauses that are too big
but well think resolution and random
formulas we'll kind of think of as a
little carrying examples but they're
just representative of many other
examples that are known to be hard for
resolution okay so what about formulas
of larger depth and CNF while CNF input
was no loss but it seemed potentially
that you requiring that in the proof is
a loss what happens if we allow a little
bit more so CNF sar big ands of big ORS
what happens if we have big hands of big
ORS of big uns of big ORS D levels deep
then we get a C 0 formulas of depth D
and no they they can't do the pigeonhole
principle either it's still exponential
for them to prove the the pigeonhole
principle now it is true that Fraga
proofs can actually prove the pigeonhole
principle in polynomial size well we'll
see in a minute why I'm not going to
talk too much about fragrance but
one thing that's still open for these
bounded depth proofs is whether random
formulas have even have efficient proofs
it's still open that random form is
these random K C and F for most might be
hard so these are systems that are more
specialized in fragrance if we go in the
other direction to get more general than
Freya
so in frege's systems the only variables
that you're allowed to use are the
original variables you can't to find new
ones and the only schemas you get to use
are the axioms and the inference rules
but suppose you've proved an axiom why
not allow yourself to substitute in that
axiom right or suppose you proved it
cytology why not allow yourself to
substitute into that too well if you
allow either of do these two things
substitution of arbitrary formulas or
extension where you allow extra
variables even if you've started it with
just with resolution then it turns out
you get a system called extended Fraga
and cook and reco actually prove that
all extended Frager things are
equivalent proofs in which lines are
basically boolean circuits and not just
formulas and in fact this extension of
resolution is kind of a natural
direction that people have tried to do
with practical Sat solvers their limit
it's fairly limited in how well it works
so far because the trying to figure out
how to define new variables is really
hard for the search but we don't have to
stop here we can even define proof
systems with quantified proof lines hey
why not do Z there's your mellow
Fraenkel set theory with the axiom of
choice that could be a proof system so
if we take in these directions here are
some proof system relationship we know
so truth tables D PLL resolution AC zero
freya and z FC and there's no reason to
see it say that it stops here we don't
believe that there's actually any
stopping there might be an infinite
family of more and more powerful proof
systems there's one I haven't mentioned
here but this is TC 0 Frey it's a
different weakening of Frager
each line here consists of a constant
depth neural net basically they
can count so they can do pigeonhole
principle and the reason why I didn't
say anything more about these is we have
no idea about lower bounds for any of
these systems up here so we're going to
focus on systems where we can actually
do some analysis on them now well let's
think outside the logic box there are
many other np-hard problems that we can
use to express the problem of
unsatisfiability that's one of the nice
things about the completeness of Sat or
equivalently the completeness of unset
so so proof complexity a lot of the work
in over the last couple decades has been
exploring a rich variety of techniques
using expressions and theorems from
algebra and from optimization and we'll
go through some of these proof system
and one of the nice consequences in turn
the proof complexity results have
actually fed back into our understanding
of these other np-hard problems so let's
start with algebra well in algebra we
can take these clauses and this is where
CNF is especially nice we start with
clauses and we can convert them to
polynomials so this polynomial evaluates
to 0 if and only if x1 is 0 so not x1 or
x3 is 1 and we could do similar things
for the others so that exact and we add
the the constraints that every variable
is equal to its square which guarantees
that things are either 0 or 1 it turns
out there's actually another translation
that might be even nicer which is to put
two variables for every original
variable that they're 0 and 1 and one of
the opposite of the other so X prime is
like the is kind of the analog of x1
prime is the analog of not x1 and so we
can just do a direct translation of the
clauses and if we multiply things out
the nice thing here is that we don't get
big terms when we multiply them out so
so how do we reason with these algebraic
systems well
goes our friend David Hilbert again in
the work before he got into logic and
proof he proved his famous Knowshon
science of which this is a simplified
special case so we start of a system
with a system of polynomials like the
system that we generated from the
clauses that system has no solution so
it's unsatisfiable and in me in any
extension field if and only if this if
there exists polynomials over the ground
field such when you take that linear
combination you get 1 or 1 is in the
ideal generated by these original
polynomials the abstract way you'd say
but we actually want to write down and
think about what these polynomials are
and with this you can get a one system
no shell incites proof system over the
field F and so you get a different one
over every field the refutation is this
sequence of polynomials t1 true G an why
is it a refutation I should have
mentioned this well if all of these
polynomials are 0 no matter what the GIS
are you get a left-hand side of 0 and a
right-hand side of 1 so the other thing
that's that's nice is this X I squared
minus x is 0 ensures that any solution
is 0 once you don't need to go to any
extension field and it also ensures that
we don't have to think about degrees in
any variable larger than 1 so they're
multi-linear in the total degrees at
most n so this is one way one could take
Hilbert system and make a proof system
of it just write down the GIS and check
just do the the polynomial multiply out
and check another system that's more
interesting is what's called polynomial
calculus it's a dynamic version of these
notional and thoughts reputations these
refutation lines are each a polynomial
or a polynomial equation so it's either
an input polynomial equation or if you
have two previous lines that are both 0
then you should know that their linear
combination is 0 for any two elements of
the field
or you can multiply by by a variable
given a polynomial and the goal again is
to derive that the polynomial one or
that one is equal to zero and the size
here well you got to write down these
polynomials somehow
so let's write oh sorry
yeah we've got to write them down these
polynomials so the total number of
monomials or the degree which is the
maximum degree of any line so and clay
governments in paliotta proved that
there's actually a relationship between
these two if your refutation is a degree
at most D that actually can be found in
this time and of course the number of
monomials has to be at most n to the D
just by simple counting and the
algorithms that do this are a grub nor
basis algorithm which you can think of
as iterated linear algebra but the
Grunder basis algorithm is a very useful
algorithm people apply in practice and
it turns out polynomial calculus exactly
captures the capabilities of this grub
'nor basis algorithm so so this is
another proof system where the proof
system really nicely matches what's
going on in practice well for both of
these systems there are some well first
of all polynomial calculus nicely
simulates resolution I thought I'd
include one simulation slide I'll do it
in the two variable form so if we've got
some a couple of clauses we've got X and
not X and this is the thing they're
supposed to infer here's a typical proof
so we do the translations with the two
variables we just multiply by the
constant terms I've done a few steps
we'll add them up we use the given we
add them up and we get the final line so
fairly straightforward and this is very
typical of the kinds of simulations one
can get now there are limits to
polynomial calculus in fact Clegg
Edmondson and Polly ATO showed something
just like we been SAS on Anderson had a
result
for width of CNF formula is implying
that if you've got one cause that's big
then the whole proof must be big
in this case it's if you've got one big
degree term then the whole proof is big
and in fact Clegg Edmondson apollyon so
did this proof first and bents us on and
we Gerson adapted it to the case of
resolution unfortunately both the
pigeonhole principle and random case E
and F formulas require exponential size
refutations didn't help too much but
here is an interesting thing that's a
bit different but from before the choice
of field F can actually make a big
difference so if you're in
characteristic P you can efficiently
prove properties that are exponential in
some other characters 2q so we get a
complex system of relationships among
different proof systems for different
fields though for most to the rest of
this I'm going to focus on the case of
the field being the rationals or the
reals let's go to another direction of
thinking outside the logic box so
optimization so we've got our same CNF
formula here we replace each literal by
an expression negation is 1 the positive
form is just the original variable
negation is 1 minus it and for every
clause we just say the sum has to be at
least one we've got to add of course the
fact that these variables are between 0
& 1 and our goal is to derive that
negative 1 is bigger than equal to 0 as
formalized here this isn't enough this
is just linear programming and it
doesn't prove properties that are true
just over 0 1 it it's the juice
properties over the whole interval of
all values between 0 & 1 so the input
formulation doesn't give us all the
information we need so there are two
options and two directions of proof that
people have used one is cutting planes
proofs and the others higher degree
inequalities using this X I squared
month
x squared minus X system okay so what
are cutting planes proofs so these go
back a ways to work of gamma ray and 59
and quatl actually formalized it as a
proof system for integer programming so
lines have integer coefficients and
integer right-hand sides and we've got
rules of addition the usual rules that
we have for addition of inequalities and
multiplication by positive integers so
it doesn't flip the sign these things
don't actually take us beyond linear
programming the key thing we need is
this division rule we get to divide by a
positive integer so if we've got a
common factor C we can divide both sides
by C and then round up and this is only
true because things are integers and if
we've got the the bounds being between 0
& 1 it guarantees it's 0 & 1 so for
example if we know that 2 x + 2 y + 2 Z
is at least 3 then we know X plus y plus
Z is at least 2 so because we get three
halves round it up now there's a lot of
work where people are trying to extend
the kinds of things they've used for Sat
solvers to work for systems like a bit
like cutting planes so far as Jakob
nordstrom and others have shown their
limitations they haven't yet been able
to get to the the power of full cutting
plane system I'm not going to talk about
the limits of this system specifically
I'm just going to go on to the other
myth oh why is it called cutting planes
first so it's called cutting planes so
here's why basically when you do that
randomly near combination let's say if
we take these two inequalities and we
just add them we get this inequality so
here's the region that these
inequalities give you we get a new one
that says everything is to the left of
that line and what cutting planes allows
you to do the rounding essentially lets
us shift that line to the first integer
points
that aren't going to be involved there
and we get to cut into the side of the
polytope so that's why it's cutting
plans anyway so we're gonna work go on
now to higher degree proof systems the
other method for ensuring zero one and
one of them which I know a number of you
will have seen the shirali Adams proof
system but probably not too many in the
format I'm going to strive here it's
completely equivalent so the general
idea here we're going to use that two
variable translations so I'm going to
stick that in just to make it more
convenient to write down and fit on
slides so the refutation just is kind of
like notional on sites but more
complicated so we're gonna have these
equations and they get to be multiplied
by arbitrary polynomials but these are
supposed to be 0 so no matter what these
things are supposed to be 0 FJ is
supposed to be positive and we get to
multiply it by this quantity so this is
a sum of products of these literals and
in their negations well both of these
are positive and these things are
non-negative both of these are bigger
than equals 0 and this is bigger than
equal to 0 so we've got these conditions
that tells us the left-hand side will
this part is 0 and this part is bigger
and equal to 0 so we're saying negative
1 which is supposed to be equal to all
of these things is bigger than equal to
0
an obvious contradiction and again like
we can talk about the degree how how big
a degree did you need to write it down
on how many monomials and again there's
an end to the order D algorithm to
actually find these Rowley items proofs
so that's one method of doing it
another method of doing it is to use the
generalization or a generalization of
Hilbert's notes on thoughts to the
positive Stellan thoughts so here I'm
going to state a very restricted forms
we we've started with linear
inequalities and polynomial equation so
suppose we've got that we can think of
these as our original clauses and these
are other constraint
and suppose those are satisfied over
some compact set then that implies that
some other polynomials bigger and equal
to zero and we could choose that
polynomial to be the constant function
minus one if we were going to refute
things if and only there exist some
polynomials P and it's we're going to
multiply each of our original
non-negative translation of our clauses
by a sum of squares of polynomials add
another sum of squares and that we get
to do the same sorts of things that we
were doing with Knowshon thoughts and
this theorem generalizes the notion on
socks but only over the reals and if for
those of you who know it here are some
references this is this particularly
simple form of positive selling sets
they're a bunch of varied versions but
this gives a proof system and we don't
need variables and a negation where we
just take that left-hand side and set it
equal to minus one and this is the sum
of squares proof system which more or
less was acquit on dira cuivre was
independently invented around 2000 the
the names were used were positive
Stellan sites and other people called it
Lister I don't think he was was doing
that so anyway sum of squares proofs on
many in the room no have been of huge
interest in theoretical computer science
in the last oh it's a decade or so and
there have been a big advances in our
understanding of sum of squared proofs
and one of the things that's been
important is the connection between
optimization and refutation so these
proof systems can actually start with
constraints that don't come from CNF
formula so you can do things directly
for optimization low degrees sum of
squares can derive all the constraints
in given by
any definite programming algorithms for
example the Goldmans Williamson
algorithm from ax-cut can be captured by
degree to sum of squares on the other
hand if we've got degree lower bounds
for first sum of squares proofs that
implies lower bounds on many of our best
optimization algorithms so I'm going to
go through one example of a class of
optimization algorithms that there's
been a lot of recent work using proof
complexity to understand and this is
extension complexity which was defined
by Jana caucus and the point there is
many math problems have natural
expressions as optimization over some
0-1 polytope but with an exponential
number of facets and the input instance
is given by the objective function and
I'm not going to go through a list of
example problems but the general idea of
the extension approach is suppose you
have some poly tope that's given by some
very large number of facets you might be
able to add extra variables go to a
higher dimension and end up with fewer
facets because each facet corresponds to
a constraint so it's a lot to write down
and then we know so this one particular
has 6 versus 8 so it tells you you can
get smaller but they're cases where you
get exponential speed-up and then you
could use linear programming up on on
this upper poly tope queue and then just
project the answer down to 2 P and a
relatively so the LP extension
complexity is the minimum number of
facets of any extension and Kothari maca
and Oregon vendrá improving on some work
of Chen Li Ragavendra story proved that
the LP extension complexity of
approximating any in a class of problems
calls constraint satisfaction problems
is at least n to the Omega D where D is
the shirali Adams degree required for
the approximation and as a consequence
for example they prove that the LP
extension complexity for Mac Scott is
own
1/2 plus epsilon or approximating max
3sat is 7/8 plus Epsilon you can do
better than and we know we can do better
than this with semi definite programming
so what about semi definite programming
there's a version of this that was
defined in these two papers and the
basic approach is essentially the same
start with the same original formulation
but lift to a semi definite program
rather than a linear program with extra
variables and use the fact that we have
poly time semi definite programming
algorithm and the STP extension
complexity is the minimum number of SDP
constraints of any extension well three
years ago Lee Wrangler Ragavendra and
star proved that for any couple results
first for any CSP the SDP extension
complexity is polynomial if and only if
the degree of doing that of solving that
STP or approximating is also constant
there their theorem actually proved a
little bit more but I'm stating weaker
results for all of these then then are
in the original papers and the other
thing they showed is that the SDP
extension complexity of the famous
Traveling Salesman problem or cleek is
two to the end of the epsilon for some
for some epsilon and very interesting
their methods their proof relies on a
result of grigoriev on something that
seems completely unrelated but is
related to sum of squares which says if
we have an inequality like this and
notice we've got this common factor two
on the left hand side and we want to
divide by a common factor to here its
rounding down because it's less than or
equal to then you get at most n and
grigoriev showed that the degree had to
be linear and that's the key a technical
result that's behind these stronger
results of Lee Ragavendra and star so
these systems aren't the only algebraic
systems we could come up with they're
static systems like no snow incites
polynomial calculus was
dynamic well very interesting result
from from last year in fact that even
though sum of squares is static and
polynomial calculus is dynamic sum of
squares can efficiently simulate it over
the reals so that's a quite surprising
result to me a pretty interesting result
so it says well okay static polynomial
calculus is pretty strong but hey why
not make it dynamic so we can have
dynamic systems for inequalities say
given so two non negative quantities we
confer can infer that their sum is non
negative where their product is
non-negative and we could add for the
square of any polynomial and again the
goal would be in two and four minus one
is bigger than equal to zero we actually
know very little in terms of lower
bounds for this system this class of
systems in terms of proof size we know
somewhat more restricted things for for
special properties and as far as they
know the best result we know is
something like the following which says
if we restrict this dynamic system -
just like that DPL l21 that can't reuse
derive formulas then a certain class of
formulas do require exponential size if
the degree isn't isn't very big if it's
it's bounded below below log n so that's
it for the the general proof systems
here is kind of a graph of many I think
of the known relationships amongst these
proof systems here this sum of squares
lists there is above all of these and we
actually know a fair number of lower
bounds for it we have these other
relations this is that one of those
dynamic systems and they could all be
simulated by Fraga and what about our
friends pigeonhole well we actually
precisely know the the boundary between
the pigeons actually maybe the pigeons
should be happy down here
because they can't tell that there's the
system's can't tell but anyway it's
exponentially hard in this lower part
and very easy up there for random
formulas we know a little bit less for
it turns out this random formulas for
this sum of squares or lacera system
actually even holds is even hard if we
have random 3 X ORS and that turns out
again to have surprising consequences
you can prove that lots of np-hard
problems require a large sum of squares
proofs based on just the on reductions
from this random 3 XOR problem and
cutting plans it's a little bit it's not
quite as you know we can't prove it for
three what's interesting about random
formulas they're not known to be easy
for any proof system so maybe they're
hard for T c0f raiga ZFC we don't know
so so that's one challenge
so in general proof complexity captures
many of our best approaches towards
solving hard problems
it covers practical approaches for
formal methods and verifications methods
such as a linear programming semi
definite program for optimization and
you know come join the working on this
field of study it's pretty interesting I
think so
thank you
[Applause]
yeah well you're the pigeons you saw
we're pretty fat I don't know
[Laughter]
[Applause]